doctor field
it's God's fault I heard you talking
about I want people to stop praising God
on Sunday and hold them accountable
amount of mouth breathing inconsidering
sure that he makes he made people
who like don't say thanks when you hold
the door for him and I would go a little
further pedophiles well that's going
away
we ended up getting caught because uh I
don't know it's a long story yeah and
thanks for saving it now I think there
is a I got to be honest it felt like
there was no ending to that but
you know what no I've had enough of this
oh Jesus Christ
we'll be right back we'll keep it right
here actually I was picturing like
that's what you say after you orgasm you
know we'll be right back
[Music]